what is the nutshell technique so the
natural technique is a method that I
created for my students and clients to
address this chronic problem I see that
99% of writers fail to tell a story that
instead the 99% situation so all I did
is I drew up the 8 essential elements
required to successfully tell a story
created the schematic it's a one-page
schematic and these are not beats in
time
these are elements that are connected
that's what makes it different this
isn't a linear isn't a strictly linear
structure if you look at the form and
folks can download my form for my
website
Jill Chamberlin calm the key is the
connect you'll see all these little
arrows and things explain the connection
between the boxes and that's what makes
it different I'm getting at the glue
that is required to tell a story that is
required to make sure that it's not
episodic a story is not isolated events
there's a connection between them and
this gets you visually is a way for you
to see identify for small what are those
elements do you have those eight
elements in your story and then are they
working together in conjunction they
need to work together and it's about
making choices actually it's about
finding out what you're married to once
people start to because it forces you to
get things out of your head and on this
piece of paper and it's not a lot of
homework it's not like I'm asking you to
write you know a long beach sheet X you
know multi-page Beach sheet to explain
it's pretty brief on one page let's see
if I can identify these eight elements
first of all if you can you want to see
visually if how they're working together
and if they're not working you can see
it right on the form so it's a way of
finding out what am I married to I
really love this premise about a guy who
wakes up and it's the same day all over
again but it's not working with this
flaw that identified the
he is naive that flaw doesn't look this
right so which one do you want to change
you want to change the floor you want to
change the great premise I probably
stick with the great premise right but
then I have to think well what would be
the right character to put in that
circumstance where they wake up and it's
the same day again they have somebody
who's naive that wouldn't really work
that's not a really good test for them
what about somebody who's really self
centric right now you can see right on
the forum okay that works much better
this is gonna be a much better test if
somebody whose self centered and self
centric if they're repeating the same
day again and again it's gonna get
really boring right it's gonna force
them to start trying to do different
things and maybe finally change and find
something better in themselves and they
realize that life isn't really worth
living if you're just living it for
yourself every day right so it's gonna
take him all that time to figure out in
this journey and this test you put him
on of suddenly being caught in a
universe where he's waking up and it's
the same day again to finally face this
flaw deep down him in himself and find a
way to change and that's how he breaks
from the cycle and also play off someone
who is more naive it has all of a sort
of a right a broader view of the world
yeah yeah right as a contrast to that
character so it's a way of just
isolating these elements really simply
it's a very simple method really you
know very simply you can see what's
working and what's not working right
there on a piece of paper and it's just
a matter of kind of small adjustments
very often can make a huge difference
between a story first of all not working
being situation not feeling satisfying
and one that's satisfying that you know
it helps you find that unexpected and
surprising ending and satisfying way of
doing things that you're probably not
going to find otherwise if you're just
following a beat sheet method or if
you're just keeping with a situation
you